yo what up what up what up what up big
love I'm super [ __ ] fired up that you
guys finally get to watch this entire
thing somebody seen clips dailyvee
quotes on Instagram a man Nipsey Hussle
you know when you talk about
authenticity in the game whether it's
entrepreneurship sports music teaching
parenting I'm always so respectful of it
it's so interesting to me and and the
admiration I have for the often
authenticity of nipsey is incredible we
talk a lot about the themes that you're
seeing me play out about my belief in
culture and hip-hop and business and I
hope you enjoyed this clip this
incredible session as I'll call it as
much as I did in living it
[Music]
yeah Gary nice to meet you man
Pino Gary what am I good hospitality
thanks Gary Gary never
how are you trying to stay ready but we
get the marketing ready and all that I
want to stop being in the music box one
Keith recording [ __ ] sit or at least
a you know stay in that zone yes I love
that
I fell out before like I got off music
and start you know like being yours
marketing and thinking about selling the
[ __ ] yeah it's like painful getting back
into music movies no so while you're in
it you're gonna stay in and this is
where you record well we kind of bounce
around we built a spot in Burbank
you know we spent like a year and a half
it was like an open space we booked the
walls out the room acoustic and scratch
he ended up moving the spots we had a
sub that's uh-huh I got what I went to
court dad work I've never missed a print
everything goes like buggin I don't know
what [ __ ] so since then we just been
like rent [ __ ] who's that paramount like
three months is that what you did mostly
em that's where you finished
you started it back in that critical
spot well you what you started with when
I first walked in here about I got
caught up in the marketing and all this
for the music stuff you just love like
you know Boyd boys just like wait to you
to meet like it just cuz it just come
natural to you just love it yeah hustlin
and get it done okay like this is I look
at like albums
but from like jay-z mm-hmm TR any big
successful artist somebody albums was
really successful someone was just like
not really and so the difference between
the ones that were and the ones that
weren't was the narrative like the I'm
about to go to jail out from TR mm-hmm
order I just got this big movie 8000
King in a song isn't it was it was
attached to a narrative mm-hmm jazzy I
watched American Gangster and I got
aspired I went to the studio
where's kingdom come oh I'm coming out
of retirement that was a story or why do
you think this last one didn't pop that
much were four four four I think I sales
wise they're saying like I mean
culturally it felt like a pop trading
culture that's it yeah a hundred percent
that's basically all I think about
attention arbitrage hat culture that's
right you go outside you hear the music
you come to the concert everybody
singing the words then you're good to me
dual title don't sprint again they did
it as like a unique release just to they
big the numbers that way well you know
to your point like there's no way he
sold all his shares to sprint unless he
was trading on Fame and culture right so
we sprints a client of the company that
might that mic works for from you like
vaynermedia like I know the CEO super
well like he's trading like Fame is the
ultimate arbitrage in our society you
know it's the ultimate arbitrage
relevant conversation gonna be respected
on that list not gonna be like
experienced as disposable it's gonna be
damaged as soon as art and then
understanding how to distribute it in
the modern way it's always gonna change
you know like when I think about
Instagram and things of that nature
it's really no different than tr
you know right like that I mean that's
what puffs I still don't even I was
watching his documentary the other day I
was hoping he'd bring it up they didn't
he hacked MTV and night he would just
show up on set pull up like Carson
that's right because he was smart he
knew every single teenagers eyes were on
that at 4:00 p.m. every but right it
people don't understand what he was
doing he was acting all goofy did it all
he was doing a hundred percent back then
he [ __ ] owned everybody who's fit if
you're one of my 41 if you're already
one and uh if you're 20 to 30 like you
know exactly what that was and he like
you know that's one now all the boy
bands and and the good and the girls and
but he walked right in there and he
started like hacking it that's what he's
always if you understand from russell
simmons to however you want to talk
about everybody in hip-hop who
understands how to penetrate underpriced
attention wins right so for me right now
like so if you're taking notes the
number one thing YouTube vlogs you get
the right hook or your project you
remember a Madden when Good Charlotte
was on Madden when you're like making
your team in the beginning right and
that literally that made them famous
that's how I think about vlogs on
YouTube
I think getting one of these sixteen
tracks on the right vlog that gets three
for [ __ ] Casey Jake and Logan Paul you
get the right like in a scene that in
itself is so much [ __ ] underpriced
attention and so like that's how I think
about [ __ ] like you could be no please
that's exactly right
I was just with the rock like an hour
ago that man just hacks every [ __ ]
platform Siri commercial ballers on HBO
movies social media
he's just something he's trying to
[ __ ] he's trying to win the world the
rock is like right he's just you know
what's crazy about the rock
like everybody like I'm leavin looking
at everybody's face like this crew Upper
East Side 58 year old white guy
everybody smiles that's [ __ ] dope you
know like that's just like people [ __ ]
what he's hungry you know what I was
talkin to its kind of honestly it's the
same should I feel I'm sure you feel -
like sometimes you just know it's just a
[ __ ] when people ask me about [ __ ]
all I do is ever point to my wrist just
a matter of time just matter time I can
even I'm with you for seconds I could
see in your face once you just know you
just know right that's right you know
it's in there somewhere like to me like
I really popped on Twitter I was one of
the first people in the world to have a
million followers on Twitter then I got
busy do my thing and like when Instagram
and all that like then I was quiet for a
little bit YouTube you know and then it
was like just a matter of time and then
I got hot again you know like if you're
good enough
shit's gonna work out that's how them
and that's what the rock like if you ask
me was first time we really chopped it
up it was just like when he was like
tried to play football when he went to
wrestling like even when he was at
wrestling when he was the [ __ ] rock
he still knew there was more I think
that every today's world there's no more
old white guy being the gatekeeper so
everybody's got a map back I just don't
think everybody's got it like that but I
think everybody can maximize their [ __ ]
so like I you know not everybody's
destined oh listen I love playing
basketball I'm not [ __ ] LeBron you
know what I mean like so I like we've
all got our talents but you know what
you guys do for look like I mean I'm
looking at music and I'm spending a lot
of time looking at it
[ __ ] SoundCloud Spotify putting music
on vlogs like no more Jimmy Iovine
[ __ ] trips over you no more [ __ ]
like you got your [ __ ] one song away
on like putting out [ __ ] like and and
like and you don't even need rap caviar
you just need to put out music and I
think the one vert above the [ __ ] that I
[ __ ] trade on is trade culture if
you're hungry and like trying to think
about your career like you
it's so hungry right now where you're at
young and like right and what's going
through your mind seems [ __ ] that went
through my mind three times you saying
to yourself in your mind this project
first you with this man this project oh
this is what it's gonna be this is what
it's gonna happen and guess what it
might not I just did apples first show
right will.i.am Jessica Alba Gwyneth
Paltrow and me Shark Tank for apps right
and me my team do your uncle time like
this is gonna be it they're gonna spend
20 million I'm gonna be on every
billboard it's gonna [ __ ] pop it's
gonna be the next Netflix they won't
call it Apple music they'll change it up
before it comes out they'll buy Netflix
it'll be big did it nope they put out an
Apple music nobody here's [ __ ]
watching TV shows that Apple music yeah
it's not how we think so [ __ ] 30
years I've been working my [ __ ] face
off I'm like this is gonna be the moment
and it wasn't but when you know you've
got it
you just go to the next thing so I think
like for me if I'm in music I wish I
could rap because I know I could be
humongous because all I would do is make
music and then lay in bed for 11 hours
try to hack on social media get in my
[ __ ] recognized notice you're one person
away one piece of content away you just
gotta [ __ ] make it and what's amazing
about music and I can't spit I think
everybody I don't like speaking about
[ __ ] I don't know so I don't want to
speak to it but one thing I do know is I
believe that every artist that ever
lived
had a lot more songs in their [ __ ]
dome than ever saw the day of life
because of the way it worked right now
everybody's fancy everybody's trying to
understand supply and demand I don't
think people understand how busy the
world is the world so busy there's so
much [ __ ] that I'm a big fan of telling
people to put out music put out music
they [ __ ] every week like if you got
it like that you know some people don't
have it I don't know but if you've got
it like that put it out put it out
people are hungry for it and every time
you put out that's giving you another
at-bat but day but they got to make this
[ __ ] they got to distribute it they're
gonna make that hat they gonna make
those kicks it's slow like [ __ ] from
studio to [ __ ] the world it's just so
crazy
I think there will be a big-time artist
in the next decade that puts out a song
a day undred I'm telling right now
somebody's gonna wake up and do
something called 365 and they're
starting [ __ ] January 1st and they're
gonna [ __ ] go I mean you got to
really have [ __ ] talent to drop 365
songs discipline hunger
you got a void what a moment but if you
if you if somebody like if you feel like
that be the first piece of ice from
[ __ ] home to [ __ ] some kid right
now he's never done you think good I
mean like like I'm telling you right now
I'm telling right now you would you
could bring especially your talent you
know somebody shitty puts out 300 you
put out 360 for whack [ __ ] you know you
put out 39 [ __ ] bangers you know
another hundred like [ __ ] solid [ __ ]
like you can have a throwaway here and
there the reason I love 365 is you can
social commentate like what people love
is relevance right like I don't know how
do you write or you just go from the
dome right so for me like like just
culture right like Game seven of the NBA
Finals like you slip a little like
nobody can beat you to the market you
just drop and [ __ ] that everybody gives
a [ __ ] about something pops on [ __ ]
Instagram and everyone's talking about
just one little line that's what Kooks
people so it hooks tit you know real cry
mean it just to have that discipline and
to put yourself out there like to put
yourself out there like yo I'm gonna
actually do this that's hard that's it's
a risk but like the reward I'm all about
risk reward right I get a sneaker like
all upside the sneaker I got coming out
like if it fails like nobody expects a
your old [ __ ] entrepreneur to have a
hot kick right but if it works right I
[ __ ] it at 2,000 people at Shoe palace
on Melrose Tuesday night and the owner
walked in he's like there's more people
here than we dropped the easies
everybody heard that and that's that's
it that's what I keep doing right and
the best part is you just have that
humility if there was six people that
are but like I lost and that's just when
you get to that place where you just
don't give a [ __ ] about what anybody
else thinks that's how you put out 365
music right right cuz that's Sunday
February 9th you put out something okay
and be like whack whack you should have
done this project and that's when you
get punched in the [ __ ] mouth and are
you gonna [ __ ] drink that blood and
just record the next day and [ __ ] get
them or are you gonna fold like a cheap
chair and be like [ __ ] me
so you have to the right DNA to go for
those kind of projects and then the all
the upside you never like if on day 3 11
right like November they're like like
Thanksgiving dinner like is the hit you
know like horses can smile you out of
make 12 you gotta print the [ __ ] CDs
you gotta get the [ __ ] Walmart Sam
Goody like it just didn't it wasn't real
right now you know it's just so
different nobody's got control it's you
and the [ __ ] kids that got it in
their ear hundred-percent cuz there's a
lot of money in the old mentality and
like you know people are sad oh are you
kidding will will I was with will and
he's just like he said music and he was
like he was basically complaining about
screaming I was like yo I'm like it's
just not 1984 anymore man
like like sorry that you can't put out
thriller and buy a [ __ ] amusement
park you know I think the truth is I
don't know I'm sure the tippy-top of the
sphere might have gotten I don't know
the label I think that what they
complaining about is the label contract
that's got them locked up back to you
how did your whole thing go down huh
when did when did you did you you said
when did you first like hit the scene
and then how to best I mean you were
talking about him in 2000 [ __ ] nine
yeah right I remember it was o nine
because we just started Vayner and I
just remember your name as hustles my
favorite word on earth I was like a
whole over that is I like he's got that
uh Haley Seinfeld whatever she was an
actress and he signed but I mean
basically like I'm so exciting and the
other thing about it is I've seen you
speak a couple times and then I've
spoken to a few people in the tech world
like set up these speaking engagements
or these conferences you know Gary good
speak salt speaks all the time when I
saw him speak it was like I've heard a
lot of people say the same type of stuff
I've never understood it until I heard
him say it and so it's like because of
your first-hand experience and then
because of your view like your point of
view and just the way you are able to
communicate to people and just have
people understand things and then like
the stuff you're doing to clothing and
then when you I watched a video when you
were in the Starbucks and you yeah now
he's like your CTO and like many rappers
have a CTO right but when he walked in
Starbucks hydrous yeah I just was a guy
right we're just having a coffee and
just sitting there no he was doing his
work on the computer but he's doing like
this
ADR stuff to like help like when the
cars are driving themselves like he's a
genius like clearly he has some
technology on a starbuck table and I had
my daughter I was just taken to the back
and it was like said I hadn't seen
before it was like reading of the bone
structure of his hand off of LCD uh-huh
piece of hardware we just caught this in
corner of your eye passing you seen it
and I know enough about tech to know
that that's not snow she goes out so I
just like bro it is better and then you
know cut the talking yeah we start
shopping young you know and he start
explaining that it was um autonomous
driving designed it for over you know
you know he start telling me a story
yeah he was like President Obama's stem
specialist for the youth and how you
know he was offered a scholarship to MIT
and turned it down where was it start
right here to Starbucks I just stopped
higher tech is oxygen of our society
right I don't think people understand
like I'm sure you're gonna understand
this we're everybody in this room
looking around everyone's quite young
we're all gonna live in a mixed reality
world contact lenses where we're sitting
here right now [ __ ] POC and VR and
it's sitting right here with us like
people don't understand oh close I think
shit's crazy now we haven't even started
this is the [ __ ] national anthem of a
19 inning game like people haven't even
wrap their head around how [ __ ] up
[ __ ] is gonna be so you're hardcore AR
like machine learning of like is that
like yeah are you doing are you [ __ ]
around blockchain yet you enjoying that
you hack it on top of the theory I'm yet
no yeah but but it's caught your eye
right yeah that shit's gonna be [ __ ]
yeah and then they got some other crazy
[ __ ] where it's like you know everyone's
selling stuff online and they set it out
we're like are you going so he is a
store like a successful store a physical
store fit Brooke Sumner he's a real
successful store and like when you pull
the phone up me pony that the shirt it
starts playing it like the unreleased
song hey are so there's a reason you
have to be in the store where everyone
else is like yeah come to my store it's
a meet and greet I might show up it's
like you actually have to go to this
store to get something right there only
where is that store it's all crash on
Slauson we need to go there you want to
see it that's the corner of like that's
right the main intersection in my
neighborhood where I grew up that's what
was there when you were close in that
spot when you were a kid
the whole time when you're a kid we
coined it as the world's for a smart
store but it's basically like he was
explaining you know there's like walls
that are content walls when you go yeah
so what your app triggers it yes I just
you know I'm called adapt so basically
what's your groove and even on the
actual like say this was a marathon yeah
of course oh I know I mean I know this
whole world real well so just a marathon
clothing adverse experience and then
once you point it [ __ ] activates yep
and what's really crazy as you know the
next iPhone has the AR kit built into it
naturally so you don't even have to
download the app it's party it's part of
the operating system augmented reality
so like you know on snapchat when you
look at it in all they're like cartoons
pop-up the way it's all gonna play out
it and you know what virtual reality is
right the way it's probably gonna play
out I mean I'm I'm not [ __ ] a
futurist but it looks like it is all of
us 15 years from now contact lenses
brain talks to it and we switch from
real life took completely being in a
[ __ ] virtual world or a are world all
this stuff you see on snapchat Instagram
like they're just [ __ ] [ __ ] in here
like here's the butterfly like that's
our life it really you know what's
really crazy about it is it just
straight-up true like like it's not even
like guessing it's not even like yeah
it's not star track it's like everybody
here in 20 years bad
Bengt locked and loaded well what what
kind of business is gonna get disrupted
right like if you actually think you're
at the Eiffel Tower by just closing your
eyes why go right right so then you
start thinking about [ __ ] like San Diego
right like where are the places where
there's just nice weather and just chill
if everything's just kind of happened
like that like like how expensive is New
York City rent like like that's where
you start debating [ __ ] like that right
I think it's all about IP I think
everything is all the pipes are dumb
what you fill it with is everything
content remember beta beeping eh like
when vape was blowing up in like Oh 809
Mike and my brother and I we had
websites we had something called bait
the bathing ape we're just trying like
just like just like hacking cuz like
cartoon scale like Vince McMahon makes
money on Hulk Hogan and Andre the Giant
Andre has been dead for [ __ ] 20 years
Vince McMahon makes money right you know
100 percent I totally agree
the music is the leverage right and
right now people people have to make
money the the basic players have to go
on tour and make money that way because
they're not deploying what you guys are
doing and like you've got a scale and
people are they're renting right they're
putting their name on something but the
company's making all the dollars but
Puma is actually not that hard to
replicate right even even the neck seat
yeah even the next
Easy's is not going to be done in with
conjunction with adidas you know like
because the infrastructure costs are
just not that high like when you start
realizing it's a health the Kayne parts
a hell of a lot harder to make in this
[ __ ] I was on ESPN Sports nation yes two
days ago they brought it you know
they're like you know I want my big
thing for last twenty ten years I've
been putting on the internet I'm buying
the New York Jets that's my thing so
they started with that they asked me
about big ball I'm like he's smart I'm
like look some of the stuff he pushes a
little far but like don't get it
confused the essence of what he's doing
is exactly right you know what screw
actually let me take you somewhere that
you're gonna like base now that I know
where your minds that I'm gonna throw
something I want to I want to get those
reaction I think the NBA is the craziest
[ __ ] I actually think the way the NBA is
structured that if tomorrow we woke up
and heard that Steph Curry LeBron Durant
right
11:12 let's call it 14 of them Russ
right
if 14 of them like we're out and now we
each are the first 14 teams and our
billionaire partner there's a lot of
billionaires out there and they ready to
roll and they're ready to roll so so
like if I'm a billionaire and I take
Russ and we're coke partners 50/50 cuz
I'm putting up the money we got a rent
arena's there's all that [ __ ] cuz teams
on there arenas but like not the NFL not
baseball not but the NBA if the top 14
guys left the league and started their
own league they break they'd win they've
got the leverage it's top-heavy we
aren't gonna [ __ ] with a league where
the best player is porzingis you know
what I mean like and I love zinger and
he's my future my hope and I hope he's
the best but like if you if if if the
number one player left in the league is
Paul George the NBA is not gonna beat
the other league so like that's why I
[ __ ] with the look with the model with
the balls are doing
people don't understand as technology
continues to like change the leverage
changes and it's not malicious it's like
it's businesses
as ystem is with the the moment demands
if you were where you have to know why's
that they're 100 percent not like I'm
sorry I haven't and that's why I'm
trying to push you and your young man
here and everybody to debate this idea
if the world is in an issue of supply
and demand then why not have the thesis
of just [ __ ] pound a now cut I'm a
man following me there are so much
supply of content that you can never be
overexposed cuz everybody's getting
pulled at so many directions so the
reason nobody want to put out so much
music before overexposure overexposure
that [ __ ] doesn't exist
there's nobody overexposed because
everybody's getting pulled in so many
directions baby that's for damn sure
but even at scale I think that you can't
be overexposed as an artist if you're
capable about putting out a song every
day and that's where everyone's [ __ ]
up they write you know how it used to be
right you come out you do your thing
then you [ __ ] disappear got to keep
that balance right gonna come right I
think that shit's so competitive there's
so much great content there's so much
[ __ ] going on that if you've got it like
that you got to go Gary how are you real
pleasure
it was the impound and dropping look how
much [ __ ] music
Drake puts out it's a lot of [ __ ]
music by standards of what we all grew
up with he's putting out more music at
24 months that people put out in their
careers well this comes down to talent
right like this is my thing with you
like like you got to push the boundaries
of how talented argue right right like
how just how talented are you there's
always like like especially something is
[ __ ] culturally relevant and this
passion is art you guys do art like like
if you've got it in you to do it then
you do it some people don't some people
got different processes right they got
out like you can't force it but if
you've got it
if your notebook is fold full if it's
full with bangers you need to put that
[ __ ] out it can't be like prints and you
[ __ ] when we find them dead we go in
a safe and there's a hundred other great
song you know that day doesn't exist
anymore
hey man NJ didn't have it like they
couldn't do that they don't wait every
three years to put out eleven of them
because you're Hackett distribution
that's what you're doing
you know what's crazy I apologize but I
gotta say it so so my stories I grew up
in Edison New Jersey good mix culture
I'm 41 so I was there like you know I
was rocking my Beastie Boy the others
but then I went to Mount Ida college
which was a 90% african-american college
right and that's where I really got into
it that's when like before the internet
like my friend moose like was like this
is Scarface you need to know this I was
like what the [ __ ]
you know like you know like and so it's
funny I am a super successful
businessman I've got D's and F's my
whole life and I still to this day
believe the people that most understand
how to hack distribution are people that
period period I think it comes natural
to you cuz
whether it's what's roll in your mouth
right now or whether it's a song you're
always hacking distribution distinguish
myself in five seconds why you like
garbage out the window and that'll make
me be like let me see this this trash
out the window right in front of each
other just listen you feel me
and it's free check it out you know if
is boo boo thought I shot the window bro
no humility humility is the [ __ ]
anchor right and even just like you know
how to talk to your audience though and
that's more important in the product cuz
you reverse engineered the way you would
have reacted exactly a hundred percent
and I think every time we have a release
when used on my market if I love Martin
I think that you got a reverse engineer
how do you what he's had how are you
guys thinking about the [ __ ] the
mutation of hip-hop like so that's
what's real
interesting to me you've got a lot of
youngsters in this room but for like the
era that I grew up in like there was one
narrative right like even if you weren't
hard you've made up that you were that's
why so many guys lost because they had
to there was no angles for there was
nobody dressing like you're dressing now
like when Bentley came out with those
umbrellas I was like well like now it's
mutating right like now [ __ ] is getting
so it's great because now it's the
fabric of our culture like to me hip-hop
is the fabric of our culture like
America what that means it's mutating so
it really it's it's more fruitful for
the real artists the one that have
humility the one like I'm waiting for
like who's the hip-hop like who's the
guy or girl at the top of the game that
embraces country music stars who's at
the top of the game that like you know
like there's so many hacks still left to
be had it's real interesting it's real
interesting to me like everything's just
like mutating into each other like like
if you really look at hip-hop like it's
crazy that hip-hop absorbed like white
nerd culture right like you wouldn't be
wearing those glasses 20 15 years ago no
way you'd [ __ ] rather be blind as
[ __ ] if you didn't have contact like
it's really interesting if you really
look at it I think there's a lot of
white space in that a lot you know what
I'd love to see something like you know
what what would blow my mind is if I
heard you went to Chattanooga Tennessee
set up shop and [ __ ] did it there and
like [ __ ] brought and look like
there's a lot of hacks still left to be
done Nashville and Chattanooga like
they're just [ __ ] to be done there's
real stuff going yeah Ron Gilmore's
[ __ ] he's done a good job you're
right like hasn't even started right
like just hasn't even started I I think
I think a lot of people in hip-hop
especially if you're born from it you're
in it I think are under estimating how
much it is fundamentally the underlining
current of our society I think it's
pretty clear all the stats came out
recently about streaming and about the
big I think so too I just don't think
that people have really realized that
like every politician every tech
developer like every they know that's a
hundred percent I know that's by the way
that I can guarantee you is hoping that
that the content creators don't feel
like what you just say cats out a bag
man that [ __ ] it's [ __ ] over like
it's just that now it's just matter time
matter of talking time everything so so
that's all I'm doing
I'm building a machine I have 1,800
employees building machine to go direct
to consumer but I've got a little bit of
a different bet so instead of starting a
new bottled water or starting a new
deodorant cuz I'm gonna buy businesses
I'm a big believer that nostalgia and IP
is grossly underrated
so Marvel was a bankrupt comic book
company but when they took the business
and they made it into movies it was
worth of Trilly so like I think like so
what's happening in the sneaker game
I'm fascinated how [ __ ] nike really is
because you can just see it but I think
if you watch carefully everything's in
place like I want to buy kids I want to
buy ponies I'm all nostalgia because
right because once it meant something
it's worth a lot more money than people
think you could start something tomorrow
called ends but if you bought kids and
rock them properly and creative
distribution it would speed up the
process exactly what's gonna happen so
that that's really on my mind
damn
I'm you know I'm just like now look but
basically I walk through the airport and
only looking at people's sneakers I'm
not even looking at I don't see anything
taste I I can't even believe how much
trouble Nikes in I couldn't even think
about wearing something else of course
they got arrogant everybody gets
arrogant I used to go get fresh fresh
that's it
garbage you know everything the other
thing is the cats out a bag everybody
I'm looking at you right now that
champion like like if champion puts out
a sneaker tomorrow and it's fly as [ __ ]
and they got the right influencer the
right hip-hop star the right cultural
[ __ ] person it's in the game right I
see it I see it was 20 years later in a
sample two seven a hundred percent
that's how it works that's why all in
Brazil 100 percent feel is a 90 brain
you know who's ready Timbo boots are
ready to come back right
are you Timbo that would be a business I
would buy if you buy I'm aware they're
huge but but be based on my thesis that
hip-hop rules the world it's probably a
50 billion dollar company if you was a
thesis hip-hop rules the world my thesis
is hip-hop rule the world all right I
just make a hundred percent in a hip-hop
album on global okay with nobody tell me
I don't care what no person tells me on
earth alright I just make the most one
any hip-hop album right now I'm global
well I got you guys here let me throw
something at you do you like traveling
or know some people you know homebody I
got asked the questions I miss monkey ok
well that's why I'm asking one of the
things that you guys should be thinking
a lot about seeing guys film marketing
you know I've been paying attention
Boyd's been telling me stuff
what people don't here's what I would do
if I were you take some of the money you
make and whatever you're doing the store
music you guys should pick four
countries Portugal Brazil pick four
countries honestly you're so creative
I'm not I was about I'm not normally I'd
be like pick this I'm gonna let it flow
here I want to see what you're about to
do pick four markets right cuz you might
say my grandma's from the otter oh just
like where's that originated Devin love
it pick four countries with Facebook and
Instagram ads and I'm talking five
$10,000 a month on four countries you
can people don't realize how global the
world's getting people don't understand
how inexpensive this is like I went to
Hong Kong and by the third day I'm like
on a pedestal America is still the
number one brand in the world America
culture correct and so for you to just
pick Indonesia and [ __ ] with it run ads
on all your little videos play that
music down banga banga banga and then go
there now London it's noisy that's what
you see where I'm going
that's why I'm like pick Portugal pick I
mean your your foot and you know much
Philippines ads are three cents like
you'll get everybody and and then all of
a sudden here's how it works right you
do the Philippines
it kills now if I get Manny Pacquiao and
you were like like Pete you got a hack
hack hack attention hack attention and
like there's so much white space meaning
that's correct
nobody nobody owns Peru and now somebody
will be like well Peru but you don't
realize like then like you you go find
some artists there and put them on heat
like there's so much of that right
what's that song book that [ __ ] the
number one stream song now like my
daughter's sing it all day that [ __ ]
Bieber and the Latina yeah like that's
hacking culture that guy was [ __ ] hot
down there but not here uh-huh uh-huh
uh-huh you know that kind of stuff and
when you're like this creative and this
entrepreneurial that [ __ ] make sense
like that you can reverse engineer or
you can see what's actually like there
just it's reverse-engineer well that's
it everybody's everything's mixing
everything's mixing that's what I mean
with like white nerd like it's like
literally for somebody like it's 41 that
watches culture every minute his life
I cannot believe cannot believe that
like NWA like merge with Oracle that's
what happened I mean [ __ ] if you look
at 1991 if you're sit yeah like 2017 hip
hop is actually Arkell and [ __ ] ice
cube in 1992 having a baby and nobody
would have thought that like that's how
you know good I think that that's that's
the times where the world is the world
is not a transitional point in the
message and culture is so powerful that
of destructive message at this point I
don't believe could exist I think that
Drake was needed most in love balance
the world I grew up to what 50 cent was
the hot senior Shueisha bro that's right
you know I mean I remember it was it was
gun culture and her music influence the
streets now everybody got a girlfriend
they got tattoos and drinking you know
I'm saying because the culture was that
influential and I think that like the
world is like transitioning you familiar
with I physics on will go away crazy got
so they're looking at space and see
where they draw on an energy to see what
type of civilization a they are so if
you get your energy from the planets you
live on your type 0 civilization ok
that's earth yep but we had a point of
transition going to Taiwan because we
are getting into solar energy we are
harnessing the atmospheres energy right
now so we are transitioning in terms of
physics when they explore space they
would say that a civilization that
harnesses energy from their atmospheres
type or understood so we transition
understood in Mattel kaku's Barry do not
mind as we said come listen
is that what's happening his day there's
a technological evolution that's ahead
of the compassion evolution or the
spiritual evolution which is in a way
catch up to the technology we got
nuclear bombs and everybody's on we can
commit planetary suicide so what has to
balance that is the culture and that's
why Drake is the biggest like I'm
thinking the love is the movement in
together new positivity always wins at
the end man Peter this [ __ ] is so basic
like like when I look at what's going on
in like the social realms like
positivity always be negativity always
wins the short game and positivity
always wins the long game it's easier to
be cynical upfront and negative and
people react to it like that's what you
see on social right and I call negative
negative you know you're like people
would rather clown on LeBron than praise
Steph it's negative like short term but
long term positivity always wins Oh ease
human race just figured this [ __ ] out
I'm always on Team human we could have
been gone a long time ago I agree so
snapchat is a wild wild moment right now
cuz every you know how it is people
overreact in each direction
everybody's like clown and on it cuz the
stocks not doing well and Instagram
copied all its features meanwhile $3 CPM
and kids are watching content at scale
like under 30 its cost per thousand
impressions so you you you know they're
gonna spend $1 your partner right
defectors per 3,000 it's nothing and
more importantly on snapchat you abduct
not just with so this isn't pre-rolls
I'm [ __ ] espn.com that nobody gives a
[ __ ] about people are seeing your
content in the middle and then when
they're engaging it's at scale so when
you guys talk and if I could be a help
if anybody here wants to follow up with
detail snapchat is grossly underpriced
right now Morgan uh-huh
grossly underpriced because everybody's
a headline reader right everyone's like
all Instagram killed snapchat go open
your app store right now tell me where
snapchats rank
it can be yeah it's a 10-second
in-between like you're kind of like
clicking everybody stories and then
you'll pop and then with you like you
should be like yeah like you know what's
funny
you know it's funny you you should
actually do exactly what the [ __ ] you
did when you were slinging you're sure
to be in and be like you know swipers
listen if you don't like it [ __ ] that's
it
you should [ __ ] Refik and do that
same [ __ ] you just look right in the
camera be like you know swipe up and
listen to it if not [ __ ] right
that is super underpriced back in hack
and everybody trades on you know
everyone's headline reading oh
instagrams women they're not looking at
the details we got we got so much runnin
on snapchat right now cuz it's under
prices America oh yeah yeah I mean well
listen they deserve it they got punched
in the [ __ ] mouth killed
I mean but I'm buying it now cuz I went
too far the other way right cuz cuz
everybody you're livin like there's
plenty of [ __ ] people on snapchat
that's how I bet my whole career I
answered every single person that
engaged with me on Twitter from 2007 to
2011 all of them 18 hours a day every
single person and so that one-on-one its
depth everybody's worried about with
it's all about depth if you got the
energy to grind well then you can go
wide nd our standout all these artists
have nobody give a [ __ ] about them they
put out a post on Instagram they have 11
people that give them love and they
can't even reply to those people
you got no fans what the [ __ ] you think
you are God uh huh you know what the
biggest thing I took away from the
meeting with the rock just now dude
let's call what it is the rock is one
he's at the man's got a hundred million
[ __ ] followers on Instagram that man
still humble [ __ ] ready put him work and
he's there and you got kids that
recorded one song once in a studio once
and think they're fancy
it's crazy yet some people fake it some
people live it
anybody want something different for the
game - yeah you can do anything you want
yeah listen everybody wants to be that
person that found you first back and no
you know like everybody people like when
somebody makes it they love you sold out
this and that the truth is if it's if
you're true if you're intense true if
you actually give a [ __ ] about people
and fans you'll always win that macro
game you're always gonna have that small
group that they'd get a high on
discovering the next thing they love
being that person right in their group
and to your point and his point and two
out of ten of them all right eight out
of ten will which is better than zero
out of ten because you didn't engage and
the other two they got to find a next
flavor of the month because they love
being that purse that's how they get
their rocks off right
they're just like I discovered the next
person I do you know you know uh huh
that's what I always loved about you you
always had that ability to find new [ __ ]
but if you liked something you liked it
all it wasn't that wasn't the hi can we
hear a little song you want to record
the most recent records of me and being
on your new album I'll [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] happy I'm here I'll let you chop
it up your way not real appreciate the
blast of them yeah I'll do it right now
thank you and then also when we do sit
down I just have so many dope concepts
is just ideas
listen I'm like always traveling always
on you got my number now you text me
three in the morning you're like what
about this I'm like like I'm into it I
want the actions I want the action
told you now what was the biggest
insight from this session leave it in
the comments because of the the
uniqueness of it I will be reading every
YouTube comment please drop them have a
great life see ya
you